when the yo estoy aqui in and wanted
miss you when I'm here in the forest I
feel very contented I feel happy because
I'm breathing the fresh air and can
listen to the birds singing is that
it'll my it's a magical place I know it
has a good spirit that protects it yo
see us again I know it was created and
given to us so the weekend nurture it
and live furniture la vamos para que
nosotros plus it'll be vamos for
Gabrielle ech and the other residents of
his village the forest is both their
home and their livelihood muliple nine
bees native to yucatan live here the
honey that the stingless bees produce is
especially sweet in Maya village
communities beekeeping has a long
tradition
Gabrielle act learned the craft from his
father this honey is sold all over
Mexico and it's even exported to Europe
no they hang estas muy buenas in a
tempura cuando you we can earn a lot in
a season one field is good even though
we have to invest by all the equipment
but it's worth it they don't see it
because it's better than what we dern
farming the fields mejor mi yo la
ganancia in a pickle to rocky and love
me to perforate inflow the village of
watchin balam lies in the middle of the
tropical forest on Mexico's Yucatan
Peninsula it's 150 or so residents live
simply there aren't many opportunities
to earn money
finding a way to live off the land
without harming the forest has proven a
challenge for six months the
International Union for Conservation of
Nature has been working with the
villagers together they want to find
ways to earn money without destroying
more of the forest protection anything
soon us okay yeah no I tanta universidad
come on is already less biodiversity
than before we have fewer species both
of flora and fauna the decrease is
widespread and significant no tabla
mente y sigo viendo the villagers used
some species for food or for building
their houses mare como para sus casas
the environmentalists ask the men and
women in the village how they use the
forest and what they plant in their
fields it's hoped that the data will
help to promote additional ways to earn
a living that protect the forest every
year thousands of hectares of forest in
Yucatan go up in flames to create space
for agriculture often the farmers don't
even use the fields themselves instead
they leased the land to wealthy
investors from all over the country who
are on the lookout for new and larger
areas to intensively farm crops like
melons it's a good deal the yield is
plentiful and that's thanks to the
climate
ok let's see from sunam local
environmental protection organizations
are worried that intensive farming will
spread further en esta situación de
mexico a Clemente in Mexico's current
situation there are many other sources
of income so they rely on profits of
this kind I mean if you ecologically
this kind of cultivation isn't viable
because monocultures deplete the soil
and pesticides pollute the water the
equal time in it but it's a source of
employment pero también es una fuente in
what can be done to counteract that one
possibility is to make farming more
diversified again did it seem that when
farmers cultivate the fields themselves
they plant props like pumpkins beans
maize and cucumbers que bien un
comprador living if a buyer from
elsewhere comes to me it's better if I
have a large selection of produce on
offer me a bowl of fish so it's
important for me to plant a wide variety
of vegetables es muy importante
diversify careful till we return to the
villagers of watchin balam producing
charcoal is another important source of
income for them only a few village
communities have official permits for
that they got theirs three years ago oz
maderas todo Tosi disz las maduras case
tan can we look for crooked and broken
trees to make charcoal que no NOS vas a
ver para we only use the ones we can't
use for anything else which keep the
other healthy trees from growing tall
and straight a Christian from those
bonitos ratos
in that way charcoal making can be
sustainable for the forest as well the
women in which ambala have discovered a
very different source of income they
founded a handicrafts collective hmm see
van de losa d'etre siento if one of us
sells a blouse for 300 pesos that's
really something in the past we had
nothing we were dependent on our
husbands siento siento solo hazel Oh
every woman pays part of her proceeds
into a communal fund and they can use
the money to pay for new material it
seems new prospects are opening up for
the people in the villages of yoga tom